ce qui est frappant c'est vraiment ces
derniers mois c'est de voir que dans ce
débat qui était quand même un débat
entre les institutions et les industries
où on mettait beaucoup en avant l'emploi
la croissance sont en train d'émerger
des nouvelles forces qui avec l'opinion
publique sert que le parlement s'est par
exemple
ces ententes sur les perturbateurs
endocriniens le parlement se fait
entendre sur le glyphosate
alors certes c'est consultatif mais ça
va avoir beaucoup de poids le parlement
va voter une résolution la veille du
vote des experts si le parlement ne faut
pas utiliser le faux pas renouveler le
glyphosate
ça va forcément faire du bruit les gens
vont me poser des questions et pourquoi
pourquoi vous votez en poupe on ne sait
pas ce qui se passe donc je trouve que
c'est en train de bouger
je me serais moins pessimiste je trouve
qu'on est dans une phase où émergent où
il ya un contre-pouvoir qui est
l'opinion publique la prison en
considération de ces problèmes et que
c'est en train de changer